was Saved by the Bell a good experience
it was a great experience yeah it was
still very close to Mario Mark Paul and
Elizabeth and I had a great time I don't
I don't have any hard memories I don't
have any bad memories how old were you
when you got that just turned 15 just
before I was 15. that's a big deal yeah
big bucks right you start earning right
away it wasn't no no no no
not at all
at all years were you once Saved by the
Bell I was let's see four years on
Saturday morning and I think we tried to
do like a half season and then we got
canceled on prime time
it wasn't until prime time until we
actually could actually asked for money
so who negotiated your contracts your
parents were involved with the business
manager and stuff no actually
at that point and he negotiated that but
it was crappy money it was crappy money
because because you wanted a break it
was my first break what are you going to
say for a kid of 15 I bet you it was
good money and and you know I mean I
guess so I honestly didn't pay too much
attention to it you know when you're a
kid and you're under pressure to learn
all those lines and everything you
didn't feel that pressure I really
didn't because they they gave us quite a
I mean when you're doing a sitcom you
shoot
you know you rehearse like four days and
then it to tape on the fifth day so
you've got like four days of rehearsal
of the same stuff over and over and over
again so you know it's a lot easier a
sitcom than in like a an hour show but
an amazing career you've had because I
think about it now 90210 and I've been
doing this 31 years Howard and you're
working that's right yeah and you've
worked constantly pretty much knock on
wood yeah after say by the Bell 90210
when I first started 90210 the girls
were not very nice to me when I came
onto the show why because you started in
later than yeah because that kind of
sort of replaced Shannon Doherty on the
show when Shannon left and that was
considered a threat I I guess I don't
know I don't know what the real reason
was they just I think having somebody
new come into an already very successful
kind of you know show that's run on its
own to have a new kind of energy was
probably hard is that the worst
situation for a young actress you come
on the set and everyone hates your guts
not everyone not everyone the guys were
actually very nice of course of course
Brian I was gay waiting so
um but the girls were not they weren't
easy how does that take form I shouldn't
say all the girls because that that's
not true but when you come on a set like
90210 and I don't know how old you were
at that point but you were young I was
20 20 21 21 is so young yeah and you
come in there and all the women are
treating you like you're an yeah
and they're shunning you right yeah they
were it's like The Scarlet Letter they
were and they're actually they were very
honest about it afterwards in any reason
so I know I can say that right yeah and
the shunning was like you'd come on set
and maybe have a table read or something
and they just wouldn't talk to you
during it or we had a photo shoot and I
had the dresses picked out for me by
wardrobe and they didn't like what I was
wearing so they'd make me change because
they wanted to wear something that was
maybe similar would you cry over that no
I wouldn't cry you're very secure I am
very secure actually yeah do you think
this what prepared you in life were
these women is that like women always
sort of were sort of angry with you and
jealous of you and jealous of your
beauty no because I didn't have that
issue I mean I had my very close
girlfriend you know when I was growing
up and you know my mom has her best
friend of 39 years now and did you call
your mom during those years and say you
know the girls are being mean I'm
extremely close to my mother and you say
Mom they're being mean to me and what
was her advice her advice was like you
know just do your job do your job
exactly
foreign